it's been wonderful being here in st.
Louis and I I just can't wait to come
back every time I come to the club
there's more activity more member more
exciting programs going on one thing
that's been really nice is I feel like I
came in like a slightly inconvenient
time for a lot of st. Louis ins because
first there was the World Series and the
Cardinals and that was that was a very
hectic time for st. Louis and now it's
Halloween so it's nice to see people
coming out enjoying everything with the
test cloud that has to offer even in
such a busy time so thank you guys all
for coming the World Chess Championship
between Anand and Carlsen is about the
start in India actually in just about a
week what does it it's October 31st
Halloween and the match starts I think
the first round
it starts officially on the 7th with an
opening ceremony but the first round I
believe is on a Saturday so a week in
two days from now the world championship
match the ends so I'm trying to wake up
earlier because the match begins at 4:30
a.m. Eastern Time
that means for you guys it's 3:30 in the
morning so good luck with that
but uh anyway I was looking at some of
Magnus's games I'm a big magnus carlsen
fan and one of my other lectures that I
gave when I first came into the club was
all about Magnus's games specifically
against and on we looked at winter Anand
an on had a really fabulous dragon when
Magnus had the most recent win which was
almost too easy in that it made really a
non look a little bit unrecognizable you
can find those videos on YouTube as well
on the st. Louis chess club's YouTube
but today I just want to talk about a
Magnus game that will give us a little
bit of an introduction to the Royal Oh
PES because this is a strategic ideas
class and we're trying to sometimes like
go beyond the opening so I've developed
my pieces what do I do next
but this is a little warm up this is a
position
more Magnus's why wait to move and win
all right so g4 here and now the night
moves and once the night goes goes away
you follow it up with g5 with the idea
that regardless of which piece takes on
g5 you can play wot right now we're g4
and notice how to score once the Queen
moves this Queen can take on g7 right
and if the King takes how does this
change matters you can just take on g7
or you could play work too far either
way okay yeah I mean Brookes g4 is
totally money yeah hmm so because
they're going to be able to take on g7
anyway which I and you're gonna have to
go back to have sex and then Queen g7 is
going to be mating probably or you can
just take one f8 in the end so yes
that's a just another example that I
didn't get ever get to show from
Carson's in an ons history now I'm not
trying to say Crossin is going to win
it's going to be a pretty close match
definitely the favorite and I encourage
you all to wake up at 3:30 in the
morning to see it just kidding so this
is a game that Magnus Carlsen played
several years ago he's only 22 now he's
turning 23 later in the month of
actually later in the month wouldn't
make any sense it is October 31st but
he's turning a 23 in November and here
he's playing against Billy offski who's
a very strong grandmaster but at the
time of this game he was only 25 years
old so I mean I'm sorry 15 years old
15 years old so very young at the time
but already rated 2600 incredible so he
played efore how many people in the
class play E for cool very good Greece
you know plea for you play d4 alright so
mom and daughter played different
opening
barely asked you played ePHI one of the
most popular openings in chess even at
the highest level I mean at the highest
level c5 the Sicilian is also very very
popular but double king bond is just if
the elite level just keeps keep staying
strong no this this playing against Orie
Lopez is something that people really
are liking to do a lot at this level
because it's such a solid opening right
I mean you're just playing what people
the classics have played for years
so Bishop b5 the Rory Lopez maintains
its position as the most testing for
white against this double King pawn
opening right people try different
things Gary Kasparov famously tried to
Scotch and was successful for it for a
little while some players try to make
Bishop c4 work people would be been
played things like the Evans gambit to
good effect in important matches and
we're talking even the best players in
the world but somehow everyone's always
coming back to the rail beds so a lot of
things you try for surprise value but
the ROI keeps returning and in fact as I
said in the earlier class I think we're
almost guaranteed to see this at some
point in the World Championship match
and after a 6
what's White's biggest move in this
position most popular as well
what do you huh not take Knight that's
possible in fact Bobby Fischer used to
play that move and he would just take
advantage of the superior pawn structure
but it's not the most popular what's
your name Evan are you dressed as an
adult are you dressed as an adult that's
like that's a cool tallying passing
you're a grown-up
yeah so what do you think
oh you were gonna say state take the
night actually not I know you guys want
to take the night because you want to
double the pawns right that why or is it
because what's the reason Isabel that's
not a good reason any time you any time
you want to capture something you should
have a good reason because otherwise you
get into this thing that we call trade
itis this is something that almost all
players have yeah I'm a nurse so I would
know about trade itis it's a very
dangerous disease and something that
really almost all players have until you
get at the super elite level like I have
this problem especially in blitz and
rapid games because the faster the time
control the more you kind of revert to
trade itis and that means that if you
see a trade you make it even if you know
it's kind of neutral or negative for you
just because it's the easy thing to do
it's like seeing a candy in front of you
you grab it you open it you eat it
you're next you're next two minutes are
planned or you're next sorry not two
minutes I I don't know how many people
take two minutes need a candy bar
unfortunately it takes me about what
five seconds 20 seconds I'm pretty fast
at eating candy so 20 seconds you know
what you know what you're going to do in
the next move you know what your
opponent's going to do and I think that
gives people some comfort that's one of
the reasons why people have this but
really in chess you should always have a
plan for why you're trading because
really what happens is when you don't
have trade itis and you only trade
because you have really good reason for
it or because you think it makes sense
your Bishop perhaps it's not as good as
their Bishop so you trade them then
you'll find that your opponent feels a
lot of pressure because they see that
you want to keep pieces on the board and
keep things complicated and then they
often a fall faster so first of all
bishops are slightly better than nice so
usually that's another reason why we
don't want to do that but the this is
totally acceptable move it's just not
the most popular because it doesn't put
as much pressure on black May
painting through the game and kind of
clarifies the black what you want to do
and then from a tactical point of view
which we mentioned earlier is that if
this pawn is recaptured black can now
play a good move that will regain the
pond so weight trying to sneak up upon
here will lead to what for black not
just development we need more than
development for a whole pawn especially
a center pond and this it's a heck of a
lot of development where you need to win
that pawn back as well Queen e7 is not
the best move because then we could play
d4 and your Queens a little awkward you
might have to play six in order to
regain it and generally we don't really
like to play f6 so early in the game
because it weakens our King right so
instead what's the best move yes Queen
to b4 attacking the knight not the queen
d3 Queen to d4 attacking the knight and
attacking the pawn a nice little double
attack in the beginning of the game so
that's one of the reasons why white
doesn't take on c6 though that all being
said it's still a jit option but the
most popular option by far is Bishop to
a4 just backtracking the bishop and
keeping the tension in the position and
the rule apes' is a lot about keeping
the tension you'll see that white does
initiate that many trades and now we
have this move b5 a more typical move
order for black is to play Bishop e7
first but instead black played b5 here
and then after Bishop b3 he played
Bishop b7 so one thing I would certainly
consider in this vision if I was white
is will you tell me what movement you
consider here
d4 is consideration you got to be a
little careful you know that there's a
this kind of there's a variation of a
okay but let me show to everybody else
if you were to take back now what would
black do I actually doesn't work
immediately we kind of need to have d6
in for it to work immediately so let's
say we have d6 in just for the sake of
illustration will the black your air
just because I want to illustrate this
tactic how can black play a good move
here a good continuation rather
black to move good moves for vodka
No we've got a really good continuation
here we can really corner one of our
opponent's pieces this kind of idea
comes up all the time this Bishop looks
like a very strong piece and it is but
black action has a way of snagging it or
trapping it by playing a series of four
seam moves so for C moves in chess is
something where it's either a check or a
capture or as we get more advanced even
attacking the Queen as a forcing move
even attacking a pawn as a forcing move
so you always want to look at those
moves that attack things if that helps
you find solutions c5 and then when the
Queen moves away push again and this
Bishop is trapped right has no mobility
so it's a little tactic that everybody
needs to watch out for in the Royal
apes' so d4 wasn't played actually
Magnus just played d3 but I'm sure this
is another consideration in the position
so you see so here of course blacks will
have to play something like d5 with the
idea of playing here and now the pawn is
not taxed anymore
but in any case let's take a look at
what happened in the game
Magnus played d3 and now after Bishop c5
he played Knight to c3 which actually
you know in the Ray Lopez a lot of times
you don't see the night go to c3 believe
it or not it seems like the most natural
square but in a lot of real Oh PES is
instead white develops the night - what
Square what's D - and why is that
why didn't why does white develop the
night - D - so often Marie Lopez can you
imagine why
anybody know why in the Royal Lopez
white often develops the dye to d2
rather than see three Julian that's true
but that's not the only reason because
presumably if the knight goes to c3 you
can still bring it to e2 and g3 or
something that's the main thing the main
reason really is because white often
times please c3 in the Ray Lopez because
it's a more closed position it's okay
to play this slower move and you know
try to get in d4 perhaps even slide
there your bishop back because remember
we were getting trapped over there so
it's kind of it's it's less usual not in
the specific line in a specific line
it's normal to play Knight e3 but in the
really low PES in general you're going
to see white develop their Knight to d2
a lot more often than c3 but Magnus in
this concrete position thought the
knight c3 was the more testing move and
now after d6 what do you think he played
here this is an important thing because
a lot of times we developed our pieces
now what next now there is one piece
which isn't developed yet right which
piece has been developed yet Nathan yeah
for right
yeah but the funny thing is in the were
Lopez it's actually not that big of a
deal because it's a little bit more
closed we don't necessarily have to
develop an immediately so in most open
positions our next step which would be
develop the bishop's a to III or to g5
whereas here Magnus I started with
another mode what other typical moves
are there in the Rye Lopez where we can
get another piece into the aim and this
is the concept that you can use in all
sorts of positions not just the Rye we
actually talked about this briefly in
our last class very briefly working one
I don't really love because in general I
don't hate it but our point our pond is
already well protected with the pond on
d3 and the knight on c3 and if we play
working one now our pawn on f2 is under
a little bit of fire a for exactly this
is a very strong move it's called a
lever so his idea is that he's trying to
yank open the I'm worried this is kind
of against my neck I don't wanted to
make like a bunch of annoying noise and
I would sit down again okay maybe okay
great got it maybe was actually much my
sweater
so a4 and now we're yanking open this
file alright because if they take it
it's open and if they don't take it we
can take and then we could either win
upon or just open the file at our
leisure
so for them not to of to avoid that fate
they're gonna have to play b4 which is
indeed what didn't happen immediately it
happened the next move but it but this
you see how this move really helps get
this work into the game and that's
something you should look out for in
chess when you've developed all your
pieces and connected your rooks and you
don't know what to do next
sometimes what you should do is look for
a lever look for a way to open the door
from one of your rocks this is
especially important in closed positions
because in closed positions usually your
works don't have a lot of open files
right that's the nature of a closed
position definition of a closed position
is a position where a lot of pawns
haven't been traded right that's what
you're going to say so
we need to tree them to open up lines
for our rocks so look for moves like a
four in your games so black play Knight
to a5 now do you think white once to let
the knight take on b3 why not yes so
there's two things the one is 90s b3
would give us double pawns the second
thing is this Bishop is really powerful
so this is an extreme no and even even
somebody with trade itis would probably
move this bishop away because you really
do not want to give that up so magnets
um I'm sure took no time we're treating
that best shop and now after b4 again
somebody with trade itis would certainly
play Knight d5 because it looks like
we're advancing looks like we're being
aggressive but it's actually the
opposite bout something things are not
so simple in chess a move that looks
aggressive because we're going forward
is actually less aggressive than the
move that Magnus Carlsen played you see
why that is because this move is going
to lead to a lot of trades right this is
going to for instance if this were to
happen and Bishop were to take Bishop
takes pawn takes see there's not very
many pieces left in the board although
to be fair I mean this is probably still
better for white but things are trading
off quickly right and if too many more
things get traded it's just going to be
very very equal right I still think it's
better for white in a specific position
because it looks like the sights pretty
bad I don't know if it's going to be
much so instead and by the way blacks
doesn't even have to take care but I
could also play something like c6
instead so there's lots of different
options here for black but 95 looks
aggressive but at least trades the move
that magnets played 92 looks like it's
retreating but it's actually more
aggressive because he's planning perhaps
to play Knight g3 and Knight f5 and
cause damage to black in the King so
it's not always so simple about forward
and backwards and in fact
that idea of 92 to f5 forced we're not
forced but encouraged Belly ASCII to
move his bishop backwards right so that
if we do get a Knight to f5 if he could
perhaps capture that night right and
make our problems double so now Magnus
played c3 we talked about that move
earlier and after takes of course we
want to take with the pawn because now
we have a chance of perhaps playing d4
at some moment Bishop retreated to be
six so there wouldn't be so much in the
way and that magnet stick played this
move Knight to g3 now Bishop a6 was
played what do you suppose Ben Johnson
played here he's got some different
interesting moves here but what are some
of the candidate moves that you would
pick think about here because again
you've developed your Knights to such
nice squares so you're not really
normally you might consider playing
working one but here it's like a little
bit less attractive because the bishop
is on this diagonal so it kind of leaves
a glaring problem and f2 if you move it
away so what are some candidate moves
you would pick here just throw anything
out it should be three would you want to
Julian's candidates um what's your name
behind Isabel yeah Rick Ricardo okay
Rick what would have maybe a candidate
move for you be here
of the dark
you would think about Bishop 83 I don't
I don't love that move because in
general like it's this pawn right here
I'd really like it but I think the
bishops kind of so as we call biting on
granite because it can actually take on
d6 so I don't I I don't think that that
is is a great way to develop the bishop
although of course you should always be
trying to develop all your pieces
another move you might want to consider
anything else Bishop g5 is a
consideration grace did you have another
option
d4 exactly another consideration and
that's in fact what Magnus played so
grace is on fire yesterday she solved
the maiden one now she's finding
Carlson's Rose pretty soon she'll be
meeting is about
I think stuff not for long right but if
she keeps coming your classes you're
both going to improve at the same time
so here we go so that's good actually
so d4 and now black took on a two that's
a really tough mover right when whitey
play is kidding
it's easy work takes rook takes Bishop
and now black castled finally and while
you played Bishop to g5 which was
mentioned earlier and I really I think
them in this position white black
probably wants to seriously consider
playing h6 I wonder why he didn't
because clearly he's not that concerned
about Bishop takes f6 Queen SX
I mean White has some activity here in
exchange for losing the bishop but yeah
maybe he was worried about Bishop h4 and
that if g5 I could play White Knight
takes d5 pawn takes d5 Bishop g5 and now
it's very hard to stop what move what
move would white play like for instance
if black were to play takes on d4 what
would I play here somebody besides don't
lamb please yeah okay
Queen ji what Queen 1 well queen g4
would be good except the knight can take
right so we do want to get our Queen
into the game but not that way
but if we want it actually there's two
winning moves here I mean there's
probably I don't even know maybe it's so
hard for white black to get out of the
spine that white could probably play
something like this and it would be good
honestly but there's two main forcing
moves here that I would consider one of
them is with the Queen Andrew where
could you put the Queen to put more
pressure on the pin piece notice that
this knight is pinned right and this
Queen can move away because and we just
take the knight so we want to pile more
pressure on that right so Andrew what do
you think so Queen f3 is a good move and
then if the King comes to g7 to protect
everything what can what you do here now
we have another we have two good moves
here as well one is about excellent and
then after Queen takes f6 no no tree
Titus that's definitely a trade itís
because trade ia this means that you
trade before thinking about all your
options No
think think harder make sure you
identify all your options before you
pick one that's really important in
chests look at all the different tracks
so Bishop f6 Queen f6 you're looking at
Queen takes f6 you're looking at Queen
g4 Jack but before you go too far down
that road did you miss any other checks
that are right in front of your face
Bishop f6 Queen f6 White has a very
strong jack somebody see it I'll put it
on the board now vez
see that's the thing about visualization
once I put it right in front of you and
now it's easy it's about exactly but you
got to see it in advance because
otherwise you don't know to play Bishop
f6 so it's easy when I put it on the
board but what you need to make is you
need to be as easy to do it two moves
before as it was for to see it once I
put on the barn
obviously that's asking a lot it's never
going to be a
easy but it's going to be closer we want
to make it as close as possible yes you
could do the night MuRF remove first as
live and now after this so I think I
think it's the same I think we got one
extra we got one extra for what it's
worth I mean we're up an entire we're up
an entire Queen for two two pieces here
but in the other variation I think it
was even more dire because here we're up
a queen for just apiece you see
so they're both winning but one is just
slightly more accurate especially when
you're playing time games where say you
only you're playing in a tournament you
only have five minutes left in this
position for some reason you would want
to be sure to play the one that's
quicker and with that in mind just
Knight a tribe is also strong
immediately so just kind of piling up on
that pin piece so maybe that was
something going for a belly off skis
head because he just took on d4 and now
what do you think Magnus played
he didn't take on d4
what else is good you want to try to
hurt blacks position
Knight of five he tried something like
that later but he started with a more
direct move remember this night is still
pinned so we're working with how can we
put pressure on that pin piece and maybe
try to fracture blacks King position
right if black is black has to move his
pawn like that that's a negative because
then his King is going to be wide open
we don't want that King to be airy
Isabel Knight h5 exactly so we just
played Knight h5 immediately very good
and then after pawn takes c3 it would be
very tempting for most players to simply
take on a sex air I mean really it's not
that bad if you were going to take on f6
here which one would you take with the
night or the bisshop think about it for
a second because your first instinct
might be different than when you look at
it for a little bit longer
how many people would take with the
night in this possession if they had to
choose between taking on something on f6
how many people take with a bit job we
only have one voter you need everybody
needs another minute okay I think we
should all be able to vote it's only two
all right
as soon as again if it's white to move
how many people would take on s it is
White's move how many people if you were
going to take on f6 how many people
would take with the bishop how many
people would take with a knight okay so
in in terms of pure positional general
principles my first inclination would be
to take with an IE because I want to
corner this gang but after we're here I
want to get my queen in the name
something like that h4 right it's
probably that's just like not that clear
after it takes you four whereas if we
compare that to what happens after
Bishop takes f6 white kind of has a star
move in this position remember that in
chess when you're when you're attacking
the really key thing is often to get the
Queen into the attack by the way the
corollary is often true as well that to
get the Queen into defense is often
extremely powerful to the defense so
what's the star move here for white to
really put the pain there's a couple
ways to try to get the Queen into the
game but there's one that seems just a
little bit more powerful than the others
so bringing the Queen into the attack
94 is one way to bring the Queen into
the attack and now what Julian's hoping
is that I'll just take the night and
then what would you do is white nathan
queen g4 and checkmate on g7 right but
instead what I would do here would be
what how would I defend instead not
saying it's pretty put a time task to
defend this position instead of playing
bishop takes d4 what can I do
mf5 or I need to stop queen g4 from
being a check so I can put my king King
h8 with the idea that if queen g4 I can
actually just play rook to e8 right
stopping me relieving some of the
pressure for the time being so instead
what's another way to get the Queen into
the attack air I love Queens you on with
the idea of Queen age sex and that just
seems that seems really powerful to me
because now if we try the same thing
notice that this pawn is also on take
right so that looks very promising
instead actually Magnus put another
really strong move in this position so
Bishop f6 followed by Queen Queen c1 was
great he instead just played Knight to
h4 and now after King to h8 he put a
knight on f5 and amazingly I think
actually yeah I think they actually
belly off scheme resigned in this
possession I think I just made those two
moves randomly on my chest base but
resigned
even though materialized he is not down
he just couldn't find a way to defend
this g7 bond properly right if you move
the g f7 pawn that weakens this knight
on f6 right and if the work comes to g8
what can white do
as well I thought you're raising your
hand you're just stretching what do you
want to take excellent very good I
thought you were trying to take on f6
that I don't like as much you want to
play Knight eight six that's another
possibility we could take with either
Knight on g7 those are both going to be
strong right because we're going to
immediately we immediately get this back
and this is now pin and the queen is
unprotected is protect is a and the
queen is attacked so really lots of ugly
things happening Julian had another
suggestion to play Knight h6 with the
idea that we're attacking s7 and that if
we take it Bishop takes f6 wins the
Queen but I can't imagine that's bad
either although after Queenie 7 it's
doesn't seem as direct all right looks
like your dynamite six you're just
weighing it I guess you're just waiting
in the exchange but it seems like the
other line was even more powerful right
I don't know but gotta be good yeah I
hear you you want to go for the
smothered mate yeah it's always nice to
check me like that right hmm so why what
I wanted to show you about this game is
just like notice how - Carlsen didn't
really do anything that fancy he just
really maneuvered his pieces over to the
side of the board where he wanted to
attack and he avoided trades right if he
had treated the Knights earlier in the
game he wouldn't have had enough
firepower to get this kind of attack
line so the Rey Lopez is an opening in
which it really accentuates that kind of
maneuvering play but it's something that
you can take to any opening always
consider before you make a trade is it
doing something good to your position
this is a strategic ideas class and
probably strategy at the amateur level
the most important thing is considering
trades is this a trade that's good for
me is this a trade that's bad for me why
or why not
we're looking at tactics primarily but
then when there aren't any tactics we're
thinking we're thinking our is this
trade is this trade going to be one
that's going to allow me to attack my
opponent right do I want to trade Queens
is my King safer is his King saver so
keep all these criteria in mind next
time you play a game and you start to
get trade itis